yeah and you know i want my kids to have
fun
and do whatever they want so yeah
quarantine might have changed that for
kim
get out of here
[Music]
keeping up with the kardashians is
giving us an inside look at what
pandemic life has been like in the
kardashian west household
and let's just say kim hasn't exactly
been living her best life
my kids are driving me so up the wall
i literally don't know what to do
kim was left all defend for herself when
it came to her and kanye west's four
kiddos
seeing as kanye was laid up battling
kovid covid19
i have to entertain four kids this is
where the dinosaurs can live
and i'm doing this by myself and it
seems like one kid in particular was
really testing kim's patience
wow okay go in there and show yeah
right now i do want to lose it
more than i give off north is like you
hate me
you know she's falling on the floor and
i was just like i
couldn't take it today north runs in
every second being like you're mean
you're this you're that crying
but shouldn't we have seen this coming
she definitely has kanye's outgoing
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend
just saying having kids is just there's
no way to describe it but it's a lot
anyway along with those everyday
annoyances i'm really freaking out
there was also one scare courtesy of
two-year-old shy
give me one sec my daughter just ran
outside by the pool and i have to grab
her one sector
[Music]
yeah thankfully
little shy was totally okay but kim's
nerves were
understandably wracked and i'm just like
you guys
i'm actually gonna die if you don't
leave me alone oh don't say that
kim might we suggest you take your own
advice for the foreseeable future
i think i gotta like chill i think
that's like my new thing